this worsening tit-for-tat has taken
relations between the two neighbors to
their lowest point in recent history
with Japan now following through on its
threat to remove South Korea from the
list of preferential trade partners it
will restrict the export of materials
and components for South Korea's
high-tech manufacturing despite Japan's
denials it's thought to be in
retaliation for a court ruling in favor
of victims of forced labor used by
Japanese companies during World War two
at the factory they gave us half a piece
of breed to eat
we were so hungry we ain't grass we lost
our here we were slaves South Korea has
just commemorated the end of the Second
World War
unveiling a new statue to the so-called
comfort women young Koreans who were
forced to work in brothels for the
Japanese army this trade dispute has
stirred up decades-old animosities
between the two former adversaries
there's fighting for issues that is in
the past that needs to be corrected
today for tomorrow to teach our children
what not to do from the past still
drawing big crowds at movie cinemas the
film raw to victory tells the story of
Korean freedom fighters resisting the
occupation by Japanese troops many South
Koreans believe Japan has never fully
apologized for atrocities committed
during its occupation of the Korean
Peninsula in the first half of the last
century Japan says the matter was
settled by an agreement in 1965 and it's
time to move on and all of this is now
having a destabilizing effect on
security cooperation with South Korea
pulling out of an intelligence sharing
agreement with Japan set up to counter
the nuclear and missile threats from
North Korea
it comes as Pyongyang intensifies its
missile testing turning up the pressure
in an already volatile region
Rob McBride al Jazeera Seoul